the architect has the obligation to  number one make sufficient income to  support the architect and his or her  family number two he has the  responsibility to the sometimes  conflicting requirements of serving the  client and number three two the  sometimes preceding and competing  interest of serving the public and  number four he has the responsibility to  have Devotion to the art of architecture  the second and third are actually  outlined in the AIA or aibc code of  ethics and not all of these points are  equal if there's a conflict between any  of these points you have to put the  client's interests over your own and you  have to put the Public's interests over  yours or the clients